et
[Musique]
les shadoks passent leur temps à aller
et venir se réfugier sur la lune pour
échapper à la fureur de l'insecte j'ai
monté des cendres de la lune
dix vingt cent fois par jour c metex
tellement c'était harassant pour les
malheureux shadoks
d'autant plus qu'il y avait le grave
problème des échelles à l'une les
shadoks n'avait pas d'échelle
suffisamment adéquat
[Musique]
il faut vous dire que les shadoks
n'avait pas encore inventé l'échelle
dite intégral que nous connaissons
maintenant ils étaient donc obligés
d'avoir deux sorte d'échelle d'une part
des échelles pour monter et d'autre part
des échelles pour descendre et c'était
pas les mêmes quand on essayait de
monter par exemple avec une échelle pour
des sens et bien ça marchait pas et même
si ça avait risqué de marché ça aurait
marché beaucoup trop lentement
de même quand on essayait de descendre
avec une échelle pour monter ça marchait
pas non plus ou plus exactement ça a
marché mais beaucoup trop rapidement
évidemment on aurait fait de descendre
en faisant semblant de monter ou qui
c'est vers ça mais c'était très risqué
parce que l'échelle au bout d'un certain
temps s'en apercevait alors dans la
confusion les shadoks souvent se
trompaient déchets
son regard sur la vie sur terre
décidément c'était pas une vie les jbe
pendant ce temps là regardez gégène
faire de belles flammes à travers leur
hublot mais comme ça risquait de devenir
monotone à la longue ils décidèrent de
mettre de la musique sur les flammes de
gégène pour faire comme au cinéma
[Musique]
et puis un jour
voilà que gégé nanton la musique chipie
voilà qu'il vient près des jt pour
écouter de plus près à faire des flammes
spéciales et même à danser maintenant
qu'il avait de la musique
les shadoks salle intéresser plus le
calme était revenu
mais est ce que cela allait durer
[Musique]